partly cloudy skies and we need clear  skies  for this super flower moon tonight  because we're also looking for a total  lunar eclipse tomorrow morning before  the sun comes up  it all begins about 1 45 a.m where we'll  start to see the earth's shadow  start covering up the full moon the full  shadow of the earth will take effect  around 4 11  a.m the moon will turn red  a blood red color for about 15  minutes it'll all be done before 4 30  a.m  as far as the blood red color and then  the eclipse will be over  by about 5 45 and the moon will be set  by then  so it is really a treat for the western  united states  into the pacific to see this we haven't  seen one in over  more than two years so get up early and  take a look we'll be live with it  tomorrow morning